et cette semaine c'est william el est
qui nous rejoint en plateau pour une
chronique santé où il ya belle bonsoir
vous êtes intéressé aux médecines
alternatives bonsoir oui on les appelle
médecine non conventionnelle ou
parallèle les médecines alternatives
désigne une grande variété de
traitements non reconnues par la
profession médicale
alors ce n'est pas parce que sont pas
reconnu qu'elle ne fonctionne pas pour
vous donner un exemple j'en ai choisi
trois florane est ce que vous connaissez
la thérapie par le rire
alors j'en ai un petit peu entendu
parler mais je ne suis pas trop alors
vous savez peut-être déjà que rire une
dizaine de minutes par jour prolonger
l'espérance de vie alors selon marie
thérèse rose qui a animé un atelier sur
cette pratique
c'est tout à fait le cas alors quand on
regarde les images comme ça ça peut
peut-être faire un peu peur ou ça peut
paraître étrange mais ça leur fait
revenu ça leur fait du bien et ça leur
apporte même un peu plus pleurer rire a
aussi un effet sur la douleur c'est à
dire qu étant donné qu'ils
produit des andonces il donc ils sont
proches de la morphine le rire
effectivement atténuer la douleur
surtout pour les personnes âgées on
parle beaucoup il faut faire attention à
ceux ci à cela leur alimentation et
l'ouest
on parle jamais de plaisir oh si on rit
on vit lyon n'a pas besoin de
médicaments alors bien sûr florane pas
besoin d'être vieux pourrir ses ateliers
et exercices sont accessibles à tous et
rire peut même vous faire économiser
quelques séances de massage il aurait
reproduit des tas de substance et de
neurotransmetteurs et d'euphorisants qui
permettent effectivement de lutter
contre le stress mais pas que ça ça peut
permettre aussi d'avoir une même une
meilleure digestion
parce que quand vous riez par exemple
c'est un exemple vos côtés le bouge donc
elle fait une sorte de massage sur
l'estomac l'intestin et le foie donc ça
fait des organes qui vaut mieux
fonctionner bien il y aura beaucoup plus
de bien fait qu'on avance oui tout à
fait j'en connais un autre qui s'occupe
de vos biens fait de votre digestion et
de vos organes il s'appelle david
baconnais et les sonos thérapeute
alors c'est pas une maladie mais bien
une forme de médecine mais écoutez le il
vous expliquera mouvement de manière
simple c'est utiliser les sons pour
équilibrer de la circulation d'énergie
dans le corps c'est une technique aide à
retrouver l'équilibré pour une meilleure
santé morale et meilleure santé physique
vous allez me dire concrètement comment
ça marche david utilise des sons pour
apaiser vos organes mais pas n'importe
quel son vous le voyez sur ces images il
utilise les ce qu'on appelle des vols
tibétains ou des bols chantants mais
aussi des diapasons
on vote relayés sur des choses beaucoup
plus psychologique comme je disais le
stress sur le deuil qu'on n'arrive pas à
faire d'une personne sur des ados des
enfants qui sont en forme de colère
voilà ça on va travailler peu plus avec
les bonnes ou avec le reiki du son et
blanc c'est plus physique entre alliés
plus avec le diapason
musicien qui a mis en place cette
technique des diapasons qui fait bien
maman a trouvé une note pour chaque
déposant donc de même façon on a mis en
vibration et on va le poser sur la main
sur le point qui est intéressant pour la
personne
alors pour résumer les diapason pour le
physique et les bols pour le
psychologique
je me pose des questions sur la dernière
pratique aux elle nous présente et
william vous inquiétez pas et celle là
vous la connaissez forcément elle est de
plus en plus en vogue de nos jours je
veux parler de l'hypnose alors pas de
l'hypnose spectacle comme on en entend
parler à la télé mais l'hypnose
thérapeutique pratiqué en cabinet et
même dans certains hôpitaux
j'ai rencontré marie l'intérêt
sophrologue qui pratique l'hypnose heil
en cours et qui m'a expliqué cette
méthode
en fait l'idée l'hypnose c'est
d'installer la personne dans un état de
détente un état de relaxation ce qu'on
appelle un état de conscience modifiée
et c'est dans cet état de conscience
modifiée que la personne que la fin
l'inconscient de la personne est le plus
sensible réceptif à tous qu'il va
pouvoir lui être dit et notamment on va
parler de suggestions donc c'est là où
le l'inconscient est plus réceptif aux
idées suggestions qu'on va pouvoir lui
faire ça un petit côté une section comme
la fille manon oui tout à fait mais là
on n'est pas au cinéma alors si vous
comptez faire tomber amoureux de vous
l'homme de vos rêves ou alors suggérer à
votre patron l'idée de vous augmentez ça
ne marchera pas il faut d'abord être
réceptif à l'hypnose et pour ça m'arrive
in discute avec son patient avant en lui
demandant ce qu'il veut ces attentes
comme par exemple arrêter de fumer ou d
un sony concernant arrêter de fumer
marie villemin confié qu'il y avait de
plus en plus de personnes qui venaient
la voir avec cet objectif
eh bien ça donne des idées pour
certaines personnes de la rédaction
pourquoi pas merci beaucoup il ya non
vous retrouver très prochainement pour
une nouvelle chronique